y se cumplieron siete días de la caída
de afganistán a una caída que fue
anunciada que fue mucho más rápida de lo
previsto
xavi a eeuu y la otan
del caos que iban a provocar después de
20 años de guerra los afganos están
completamente desprotegidos fue todo por
nada
no a eeuu si los aliados de la otan
básicamente se guiaron por sus servicios
de inteligencia y sus servicios de
inteligencia han estado 20 años
de hecho principalmente el de los eeuu
al estado 20 años dando en medias
verdades información falsa como lo
reveló hace unos meses el 'washington
post' si un libro reciente llama los
papeles de afganistán
esto creó unas inercias en el cual
especialmente la gran mentira podríamos
decir era creer o querer creer que a
phoenix el gobierno afgano podía
resistir por un ejército teóricamente
formado un ejército formado por eeuu
teóricamente con trescientos mil
efectivos para dar a los datos están
saliendo es que no sería probablemente
más de 50.000 efectivos
vamos a ver si reales los que podían
combatir por otra parte era un ejército
sin ninguna convicción sin ningún ideal
frente al avance del talibán o sea no no
diría yo ni mucho menos que es
premeditado pasando pero sean guiados
por una serie de información creada por
los mismos servicios de inteligencia
falsa como digo medias medias verdades
medias mentiras que les llevaron al
convencimiento como dijeron hace pocos
días atrás de que el gobierno afgano y
el ejército afgano podría aguantar entre
seis meses hasta un año y al final cayó
en una semana que se puede pronosticar
para cuando acabe la retirada de las
tropas extranjeras que pasará con
afganistán una vez que las potencias
occidentales salgan del país y que se
deje de prestar atención a la situación
de esas naciones de posibilidad de
ustedes de una relación diplomática con
el grupo extremista
no en el corto plazo y depende de quién
quiero decir rusia china y pakistán
irán van a ser de alguna manera los
grandes sino grandes pero sí
considerables ganadores en esta partida
son países que van a establecer y ya
están manteniendo sus embajadas
aquí están siempre ha sido el que ha
apoyado el talibán
en china que en ella grandes intereses
en este país que es un país clave que
políticamente rusia ya ha dicho que va a
establecer buenas relaciones e irán
tiene interés especialmente porque tiene
varios millones de afganos de las
guerras anteriores y de las de los
últimos 20 años los tienen como
refugiados en su territorio o sea otra
cosa es que relaciones van a tener con
occidente pues para tardar como va a
tardar el flujo de fondos que acaba de
cortar el fondo monetario internacional
yo creo que internamente va a ser un
periodo muy difícil un periodo en donde
probablemente el talibán tiene
experiencia de guerra pero tiene poca
experiencia de gobierno y al mismo
tiempo
digamos tiene fondos por parte de por el
narcotráfico que controla y por todo lo
que es un sistema interno de impuestos
al movimiento de bienes dentro del país
pero esto solo no le va a alcanzar para
gestionar este país pero también como
está pasando ahora concilia
probablemente cuando sea plan que toda
esta situación y pasen unos meses por
comportó también países occidentales
comenzarán pragmáticamente a establecer
relaciones a menos que los talibán sean
muy brutales en su represión sean muy
brutales y esto impida de alguna manera
luego de la vergüenza que se está
pasando en este momento impida que
puedan restablecer relaciones mire muy
rápidamente joe biden sigue defendiendo
que la decisión correcta fue la de la
retirada se cumplió el objetivo de la
misión militar en afganistán pero que
tan golpeado queda el poderío
estadounidense en la escena
internacional
el objetivo o sea el objetivo que se
cumplió fue el primero de todos ese plan
que hasta dos pies hace 20 años atrás
que fue que no hubiera ataques
terroristas desde afganistán pero
después eeuu si los gobiernos de eeuu
plantearon hacer lobby llama reconstruir
o construir el estado afgano ese ha sido
un fracaso absoluto de que eeuu debería
retirarse y creo que es un hecho que en
el cual por lo menos mucha gente estamos
de acuerdo el convoy de la forma en que
se ha hecho la retirada es la vergüenza
y el producto desastre también por la
forma en que se amparó se protegió y se
lidió como un paraguas a muchísima gente
y al desarrollo de una sociedad civil
dentro de afganistán
es incorrecto plantea vaivenes aseguran
también una media verdad